how many beers would it take for you to
drink for me to beat you in a classical
chess game that's a very difficult
question uh cuz I'd probably sober up
during the game so I'd probably have to
keep drinking probably start with 20 and
take it from there 20 okay how what's
the size of the cup um pints wow okay 20
in your entire career have you ever had
a day where you went I think this guy
might be as good as me in
chess no uh well I mean not not not you
know since not the last 10 years for
sure okay has it ever
been this guy might be kind of close to
me if I have a bad day yeah uh I would
say Fabia his best was um very close in
In classical for sure